[Narrator] The answer is 0.32, and we're computing this using the conditional probability rule,
so that means we need the probability of A intersect B,
divided by the probability of B.
In this case, B is the case where X is not A so that's 1 minus the probability where X is A,
which is equal to 0.92.
Since the probability that X is A is 8%.
The intersection probability is the probability that X is a vowel intersected with the probability that X is not A.
That's the probability for all the vowels other than A, which is adding 0.13 + 0.07 + 0.07 + 0.03,
and there we get 0.30, and when we do the division, we get 0.32,
and this makes sense.
Previously, we computed the probability that X is a vowel by itself with 0.38.
If we know X is not A, we expect that probability to go down,
which is why we get the lower value 0.32 here.